scusi potrebbe sentimenti primi
l'ombrellone e comunque con tutti i
soldi che paghiamo per sé almeno farcelo
trovare già aperto un giorno no non
voglio niente non si disturbi guardia di
una maniera incontra perché come lei
lavora in nero vorrei semplicemente che
non rompesse le balle chi come me lavora
tutto l'anno per pagare le tasse è
capito vada data si è mio marito drogato
un tavolo per 12 all'ombra e allora
proviamo installa fine di mare senza
pesce senza oggi senza sale grazie gioia
l'ombrellone ma la crisi non c'è
problema andiamo a prenderci un caffè ma
o apri vita come sai tutto bene alle
picciriddi e tua figlia alla grande e
tua suocera tutto vengono mai come fate
aspetta ci penso io dico ma carmela toto
vengono e se il tono riprendete quei due
per mio così state a posto ma mustafa
già passato non ho niente ci hanno detto
di mettere da parte il pareo quest'anno
cose belle a ma voi avete già mangiato
vecchio guardato qualcosina per
accomodare così non vi fate mangiare da
sola allora cosa volete in pasta al
forno parmigiana male conciato banale un
pochino di insalata di riso quello che
volete